Hi everyone, I'm Dogen.
Thank you for surpassing 500,000 people.
Well, if you're a viewer of mine, I think you'll understand, but on this channel,
the words "good at Japanese, good at Japanese
" have
become a meme, and it's
become the
punchline of many jokes.  Viewers have
been asking me for a long time when the so-called Jaws merchandise will be released
.  But I thought that if I was going to
make
something anyway, I wanted to make
something interesting.
I wanted to make a product that Japanese people wouldn't
say I'm good at Japanese, so that's why I
've been thinking about the design for a long time.
I would like to introduce to all of
you.To begin with, I
chose a seal design.In Japan,
when you prove something,
you use a seal like this.
If
that's the case, then I thought it would be interesting, and well,
you probably won't be told that you're good at Japanese, and on top of that,
I thought it would be interesting because it also includes traditional Japanese culture.
I'm going to do it right away, but from now on, I want
to change into new goods and show them to
everyone
.
After all, it's written that way, and to add to that
, in a sense,
I'm not saying that you're good at Japanese, either.